hello and welcome to swipe coming up the
online Big Bang we take a look at how
the digital universe is expanding
keeping connects it we've a dummies
guide to some of the latest smart tech
the butterfly effect we're getting in a
flap is a recycled robot insects plus
ghostly mysteries and murderous worms on
this week's games review from wireless
technology to smart devices given how
connected we are these days that's
hardly surprising to hear that we all
generate a lot of data the number of
things we own which can be synced up to
the Internet is nearly 200 billion and
according to one you study by 2020 the
digital universe will be almost 10 times
the size of what it is now it's growing
at an astounding pace can we keep up
Katie Spence has been trying tapping on
any one of these services brings up the
sky on my screen and then allows me to
control it as I would using a normal
remote control connected and intelligent
at finite solutions smart home in Leeds
visitors are invited to get a feel of
where our houses are heading from
automated blinds to hidden cinemas
machine that can speak to machine with
the controls already in our hands do we
have a computer story all of our media
and music videos all of our photographs
moving down CCTV relay that saw nos
which is a streaming music service and
below that amplification which is
powering the speaks in the various rooms
of the house the key to making any good
smart homework is these racks it's
estimated there are around 14 billion
devices already connected and
communicating over the Internet that's
just seven percent of what could be up
and running online at the moment the
amount of information in our digital
universe could fill a stack of ipad air
tablets that would reach almost
two-thirds of the way to the moon as we
get through four point four trillion
gigabytes of data but in
just six years time it'll be around ten
times bigger and the information could
fill just over six and a half stacks to
the moon as our data usage source to 44
trillion gigabytes figures so vast it
can be difficult to comprehend but as
streams of data become larger that also
presents bigger challenges step inside
the London offices of big data experts
EMC and you can hear the buzz of what
the tiniest fraction of that data sounds
like high-capacity drives like these
will play an essential role in managing
and securely storing a business's data
organizations I have to going to have to
do probably three things significantly
differently they will need to use
different technologies predominantly
software-based that will automate many
of the things they've done in the past
secondly they'll have to have different
policies governance around things like
security and we predict something like
the thirty percent increase in the
number of IT people required monitoring
and protecting our houses through
connected technology should make it
easier to keep the burglars at bay but
if everything we use is up online will
it leave us vulnerable to cyberattacks
it would be very hard tack into the
systems because you not only would have
to be a computer hacker you would also
have to be able to program the bespoke
control systems that we use to actually
have access into a client's house so it
is a valid concern but I don't think
it's something that ninety-nine point
nine percent of residential homeowners
would actually need to worry about how
much data we use has rocketed as a
result of smartphones and tablets but
with connectivity in the home set to
become an integral part of how we live
our digital needs are likely to explode
Katie Spencer Sky News you watching
swipe coming up the robot butterflies
which could teach us a thing or two
about recycling but first given how fast
our wireless world is becoming we
thought we'd check out some of the very
latest digital devices that are designed
to make our lives easier Jeremy white
from a wired magazine is certainly no
dummy when it comes to smart text
we asked him to take us through a few so
the I grill to the uncle to is basically
some sort of smart device that you can
plug into you or iPhone or any other
smartphone and what it essentially
allows you to do is monitor what's on
the grill from your mobile phone when
the meat reaches the temperature you set
it to the phone will get Center and
alert from the I grill to letting you
know that everything's okay now the time
to finish cooking so you won't end up
with a state like old whether there's
not much to not like about it it's hot
in the cost it's not it's not cheap it's
about two hundred dollars for something
that really only has one use and also I
would have liked to seen this have
rechargeable batteries rather than just
standard AAA batteries so the canary is
six inches high and looks like a small
cylinder with a black center stripe and
it is essentially your home security
device it's got an HD camera high
quality microphone temperature sensors
night vision movement detectors it's
even got a siren built into it as well
as a speaker and when it sets off an
alarm or an alert it sends you a text
message or alert on your phone saying
something's happening which I wouldn't
expect to happen do you want to do
anything about it it's tremendously
useful and the one of the other great
things about it is there's no wires
involved it literally just plug and play
ders put it in the house and you're off
and running the only problem with the
canary is that it's actually taken their
great little time to get to market we've
been waiting and waiting and waiting for
it to arrive and at the moment obviously
it'll be only available in the US but it
will come to the UK so I'm told so next
we have the parrot flower power to bring
out your inner hippie it is a connected
smart device that allows you to monitor
how happy or how sad your plants are it
is Bluetooth connected not Wi-Fi so you
need to be reasonably nearby to the
device for it to actually work and
communicate with your smart device
prongs that you place into the soil
measure temperature of the soil
measure how hydrated the soil is also
levels of fertilization as well so you
get these alerts from your plant and you
can name your plants so I've named mine
Stan Lee and Stan Lee sends me text
messages saying I'm thirsty or I'm
hungry and so if you're useless in the
garden and have don't have any green
fingers whatsoever like me it's almost
like I sort of first aid for those
plants lapka is a personal environment
monitor so these are series of little
devices very nicely designed i must say
that connect up to your iphone and
android devices as well and monitor the
environment around you it's as simple as
that there's a there's a Geiger counters
a radiation counter there there's a
humidity temperature sensor in there too
one for measuring electromagnetic fields
it's always nice to know about the
quality of EDS and what's around you and
and so it's it's a nice idea executed
well it's just a matter of how much
you'll get out of this device you're
watching swype coming up my America's
secret service will help sorting out the
sarcasm but first chances are you've got
at least one old mobile phone in a
drawer or cupboard somewhere at home but
what to do with it how about building
something new out of your old technology
Stuart Duncan's been taking a look at a
group of designers who were taking
recycling to the extreme they're
beautiful inventive and kind of scary
these for digital butterflies are made
entirely from old mobile phones the
insects were created by a team of
designers to encourage us to recycle our
old devices we thought there's a fun way
to take these things that otherwise
would just go in the bin and make
something beautiful and and play for
hopefully hardware from a range of
phones has been used and you'll see
different parts here screens sim cards
circuit boards and complete handsets
they took more than
months to build but will the message get
through the main problem in headphone is
the battery and one battery from a
mobile phone if it's ends up in the
wrong place can pollute 600,000 liters
of water so it is a really important
issue to get mobile phones recycled when
they do get to the end of their lives
the butterflies can all be cooled and
have a unique reaction based on the
phone number of the person who's ringing
them each one is modelled on a different
species they're really wildly ranging
colors and patterns on on butterfly's
wings and so some of the guys I work
with wrote some software that would take
people's phone number and use that as a
seed to generate these wing patterns so
they we designed some visual frameworks
and then the number decides how wide a
line is or how larger circle is whatever
you think of these robotic insects
they're certainly an interesting way of
encouraging people to recycle their old
tech they were first shown off at the
Natural History Museum in London and
we'll also go on display at the o2 arena
in the summer Stewart Duggan Sky News
you're watching swype coming up the
worms return in this week's games review
but first here's a roundup of anything
you might have missed over the last few
days apples revealed new iPhone and iPad
features to help people monitor their
homes and their health the tech giant's
made the unveiling at its annual
worldwide developers conference in San
Francisco it showed off a new software
for macs called Yosemite and its iOS 8
operating system both of which are
designed to make it easier for users to
search and share content the software
will come out in the autumn that's when
the iphone 6 is rumored to be launched
pretty much anything that you can think
of that you can stick an apple in front
of there's always a rumor and then
whenever it happens we normally come
away slightly disappointed because all
the hype and it's speculation just
passes out to realization and reality
that will normally launch the iphone 6
in around about the sep tember time
frame is obviously promises of a new IP
as well the iPad the iphone 6
interestingly the latest rumor is that
it will feature a bigger screen after
apples seem to be sort of a slow to
adopt the larger screens that most of us
other competitors like Samsung HTC have
for quite some time now Twitter wouldn't
be Twitter without the endless stream of
sarcastic tweets but it would see in the
US Secret Service need a little bit of
help working out what's supposed to be
funny it's put out a working tender for
someone to create a special system that
can help them sort through large sets of
social media data it wants a program to
and I quote here detect sarcasm and
false positives we could soon be able to
use bitcoins to pay for purchases on the
app store apple has changed its stance
on virtual currencies for the first time
up until now they've been banned on the
company's devices however Google's
platform android already accepts digital
money the crowdfunding site Kickstarter
is relaxing its rules a ban on health
products cosmetics eyewear and
electronic surveillance equipment has
been lifted it says the move is to make
things simpler but it'll also help when
it comes to keeping up with the rivals
like IndieGoGo and finally want to know
the secret to making a perfect cup of
coffee well a chemist at the University
of Bath has been using a supercomputer
to work out how to get the best taste
from your hit of caffeine apparently it
all comes down to how ions in the water
interact with the chemicals that give
coffee its flavor the best results come
from using a reasonably hard tap water
with high magnesium levels which can
increase the extraction of the coffee
into water so now you know on this
week's games review Weaver ghostly
mystery to solve comic fables come to
life and murderous worms so who better
to take us through that eclectic mix and
the gaming expert that you see James so
it's a pretty slow time in the games
industry at the moment everyone's
gearing up for III so not that many
tiles out but there is one committed
soul suspect so published by Square Enix
and
by airtight games it's quite interesting
take on a murder mystery in that you're
solving your own murder don't like white
unless you're hurt so you play as you
know this uniformed cop he's called
Ronan O'Connor great name and he you
know he gets killed at the very
beginning of the game and he comes back
as a ghost because he's got unfinished
business and he has to solve his own
murder so it's quite cool on that as a
ghost he has these abilities he can
teleport he can possess people there are
loads of ghosts walking around you can
talk to the meal and so it's kind of you
know this a little bit of past and
present in terms of the story you know
there's a lot of twists and turns you're
looking at you're after this Bell kill a
guy who who keep spraying on younger
women and it's all a bit mmm so it's
quite cool and it's quite slow paced and
you know you get into it but there are
some pretty daft decisions you know the
girl there's demons in it it don't
really need to be there it's quite fun
and I'll get you thinking well because
there are a lot of twists and turns to
it so let's murdered soul suspect
so the wolf among us is an episodic
series by Telltale Games and it's based
on the fables comic book series which is
basically about fairy tale creatures who
are forced from their homeland by the
adversary and they're forced to live in
a borough of New York run this rundown
bar called Fabletown we need to solve
this before something else happens the
big overarching story is that someone is
murdering Fabletown citizens and as big
but you're trying to solve these murders
and of course nothing's as it seems
because there is this element of magic
involved in terms of gameplay there's
not that much you wander around a little
bit you look at some things and but it's
mostly about these conversations and you
can shape your Big B into how you want
him to play out so he he does have this
gruff exterior and this is kind of dark
past but as big but you can choose
whether to be a nice kind of Big B who's
searching for redemption or you can be
just as hard as he was gonna go in there
and do whatever it takes to get the
answers and so episode 4 is great it's
quite short as well but there's four
episodes so far you can play through it
like an afternoon right it's get me
really excited for the phenomena
so what do you say about worms it's sort
of it's an ongoing game series pretty
much everyone's played worms you take on
a team of five worms and you against
another five and you use all these all
this manner of crazy it's turn base you
use all these crazy weaponry to try and
kill all your opponent's worms and it's
made by British developer team 17 who I
think of one of the the longest-running
independent developers worldwide which
is really cool and they're based up
there up north and worms battlegrounds
is worms on next gen consoles so it's
you know obviously it's got that
next-gen Sheen and everything but it's
kind of the most complete worms game so
far and that you can customize all your
characters not just the names you can
look like there's all these great set
pieces and of course there are all these
wacky weapons so you've got like winged
monkeys and the whoopsie cushion all
this kind of stuff and it's just this
great turn-based gameplay and it's a
worms game but you know it's it's kind
of nice to support British developers
like that and you know it doesn't enjoy
game of worms you know get get your
friends round past the controller
subsequent battle back to duluth thanks
Lucy that's it for this week remember
you can catch up with the breaking tech
stories all week on Sky News for ipad
our smartphone apps and of course can
you stop on see you next time